beautiful salt lake city utah which is
home to 10
colleges and universities and a lot of
students who will be voting for the very
first time in a presidential election
look at this recent fox poll that shows
a large majority of voters
under the age of 30 favored democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
so we sat down with five students
registered in this historically red
state and asked them about the issues
that will guide their vote
with four weeks to go
overall how does kovid weigh
on your vote and how you might vote do
you think the president's handled it
well do you think joe biden
would handle it better i watched the
debate last week and i felt like joe
biden did blame
president trump for it a little much
however that being said i do think that
there
are a lot of things he could have
handled better he knew about it
pretty early on and i think in hopes to
not shut down the economy
might have not taken action that would
have been beneficial to do early on
which has endangered a lot of americans
lives and so while i wouldn't blame the
entire like crash of the economy and
covid on president trump i do think that
it should have been handled better
each state has their own governor and
they've created their own response and
so
the things trump has done like tried to
shut the borders and
got the ppe equipment to all these
governors he's actually been praised by
democrat governors for doing that with
donald trump's rhetoric against masks
and acting like it's not a big deal when
it's a simple scientific fact
is detrimental to us um you see
republican areas like utah county with
higher cases and less people wearing
masks
when this can actually be prevented
by a mask in a lot of ways so i think
donald trump
handled this poorly because he's setting
a terrible example for the american
people and the citizens of the world at
large
of how to take measures to prevent this
from happening
i'm going to ask each one of you you
know what's the number one issue for you
ben um i would probably say climate
change is definitely one of the most
important i would say economy
economy i'm big on foreign policy
foreign policy
i'm gonna have to pick three so i'd say
rebuilding the economy given the state
that it's in
climate change and then also health care
okay
so yeah the economy um yeah okay
so i want to do the same thing and i
want to ask you each you know if you
one word to describe president trump one
word to describe president trump
that i would use is irresponsible
reactionary powerful
powerful selfish
very outgoing okay interesting and let's
do the same thing with joe biden
ben you want to start leader
uh very old dedicated
slow
confident interesting
so when you look at the state of utah
do you think regardless of how you feel
raise your hand if you think that
president trump will win this state
everybody when you look at the united
states right now
do you feel like it's headed in the
right direction or do you feel like it's
headed
in the wrong direction i would say that
given our current state we're
backpedaling
by decades especially when it comes to
civil unrest
all the progress that we've made over
these years is being retracted
by leaders of the conservative party
currently
and i think with the joe biden election
we can get back
on track and take some steps forward so
you support joe biden
do you have any concerns about him there
have been a lot of talk about you know
about his abilities to do the job does
that concern you at all
well he certainly wasn't my number one
choice in the primary and he wasn't even
my top five
but i think as i've gotten to know him a
little bit better as a candidate
i've become more confident in him i
think he's a steady leader that we need
right now
is it hard for you guys in college the
trump supporters do you find
that people are comfortable with your
support for the president
in utah in general it's pretty
conservative but i definitely have some
friends who
have a hard time with my views so yeah i
feel like especially on college campuses
and free speech is i feel like it's
under attack
as a conservative group on campus when
we bring a right-wing speaker on campus
when we
are even holding meetings or just simply
tabling our properties are vandalized
we're harassed we're called names and
there's a
amount of sabotage from left-wing
student groups that try to
get us to not hold meetings and in that
sense it's extremely hard i believe
conservative speech is under attack in
college campuses do you feel like
quok and people who feel like him have
the right to
to speak out and hold their meetings and
say what they want to say ben
absolutely i mean so at weber state
university i'm the vp of the
democrats the college democrats and we
also have a college republicans chapter
and we try to work together whenever we
can to do
joint events and that's something we're
we're looking we're looking to do
because
if we can't have conversations with
someone with different views then
we can't make any progress at all so i
certainly can respect people with
different opinions than me
raise your hand if you think that you
that your friends the people you know in
college
that do you think raise your hand if you
think they will
all definitely vote
a few there's always going to be those
people who
maybe are in the middle ground and feel
like they shouldn't vote um however i
disagree with them
and think that they shouldn't vote third
party or shouldn't stay at home and they
should get out
to the ballots and exercise their right
to vote do you have concerns as a young
person in america that that there's
a fundamental change coming that that
people are leaning
more to the left does it concern you
or not it is very concerning i really
wish that in the
vice presidential debate especially vp
pence and
senator harris would be able to uh talk
about policy
substantive and have substantive
arguments constructive arguments
so that voters can really make an
informed
decision and it and i believe that it
just
sets a precedent and it sets a climate
for the um
for the political atmosphere it's hard
for me to see myself voting for like
republicans like president trump um just
because i do care about like immigration
and several other issues
and i think many younger voters are in
the same boat where socially they might
be a lot more moderate or even liberal
and would love to be able to support
conservative candidates raise your hand
if you think that
joe biden will win
three do you think president trump will
win
you're not so sure yeah no
thank you guys very much for your time
today